a local TV anchors career leap into a
beauty entrepreneur more than paid off
for her big time Jamie Kern Lima is her
name she landed on Forbes list of
America's richest self-made women go
Jamie she's the co-founder and CEO of it
cosmetics like the name the company
works with plastic surgeons great
problem solving beauty products FEMA has
pitched them more than a thousand times
on QVC show how they work she takes off
her makeup to reveal her own skin
condition that causes redness the
world's largest beauty company L'Oreal
purchased it cosmetics last year for
more than a billion dollars in cash
Jamie Kern Lima joins us at the table
welcome thank you so much so great to
have you here you are a local TV anchor
yes you were in our business you
suffered from eczema right what led you
then into this business yeah so I
actually thought I would be a journalist
my whole career like I loved hearing
people's stories and but I have skin
issues so I have hereditary rosacea and
hyperpigmentation and sparse brows and I
quickly realized that most makeup looks
good when you have flawless skin but
when you actually need coverage it
doesn't it would start creasing cracking
making me look older so I feel you know
if there were other if I was feeling
this way I wanted to solve that problem
for myself but also for other women out
there that couldn't find makeup that
just made them look like themselves like
their most beautiful version and that's
when the idea is great but what you did
most of us in this business don't want
people to know that we have certainly
any physical flaws not only did you do
that you exposed it for everybody to see
and it's paid off in a very big way for
you so what did you do exactly well you
know I am I are authentic missions every
woman is beautiful and so I was going to
stand behind that right and so you know
we took a huge risk when we went on QVC
and you guys probably know when you see
the beauty industry you usually see
women that all are sort of like the same
definition of what aspirational is the
same age the same skin tone like
flawless skin and like that is not real
life and and I want every woman to know
that she's beautiful so I went on air
took my makeup off showed my rosacea and
then instead of having like models that
are all like they look like they're 12
and they say no we have
model on his you know in her 70s every
skin tone every skin issue and I wanted
women to know that these are products
for her not only the products but it's
really more than that it's about you
know just remembering that every woman
is beautiful that they matter that she
matters yeah I think we all get the
bigger picture of that but to charli's
question because it says you started it
in your living room what does that mean
are you you and your husband are you
mixing potions what are you doing
exactly involved yeah yeah so it was
really a dream I'm not from the beauty
industry but I knew I needed to solve
this problem or be of service in a
greater way so yeah I I started we
started the business in our living room
didn't pay ourselves for the first three
years we assembled an advisory board of
plastic surgeons dermatologists and
chemists that really knew skin and we
started making skincare but put coverage
into it and where is totally different
on your skin but it is a true
entrepreneur story we are doing in your
living room with you guys oh my goodness
everything Gail from learning how to
pack boxes and my middle name is Marie
summer ear and customer service I mean
every single job that you can imagine
and I just have to say you've got a lot
of nose though we started yeah so
nobody's waiting here right now Gail I
hope is proof to every one of your
viewers that their dream is possible and
we got so many knows so and that's
probably I think one of my biggest
lessons as an entrepreneur where you
went to beauty companies Sephora also
all of those guys anyway we're not
interesting I knew it I believed in it
QVC said no more times than I could
count more times than I could cry mr.
Boddy they finally say yes I think that
well okay and so to Sephora did it all
today all said no and Charlie now we're
so blessed to be that the number one
brand at QVC and Ulta and you sold the
company to L'Oreal yes one of the great
big cosmetic companies in the world yes
so what's happening here in the u.s. is
you know I feel like women are
connecting you know I get emails every
day women saying like I feel beautiful
for the first time or the first time in
a long time
so we internally in our own company
tried to scale this globally and we
launched into Sephora in Southeast Asia
and I realized it is hard you should um
so I'm hoping L'Oreal can help us take
our mission nila but
thank you for coming here and share you
Jamie you know what it means to be up
against the hard clock but you sold the
company but I'm still running it and you
are an it girl I think my job is what
are the best companies there Thank You
Jamie they're into science too yes yeah
Meeker and Lima is her name remember it
cosmetics